They just know how much it enhances after you nap. Right?
How much more you can retain it all comes down to who is funding the research,
so, Oh, sure. Right. All the sugar industry was saying, it's not that bad.
And it's like, if the pillow industry is telling you take naps,
unless it's my pillow, which I'll buy it. Cause it's America.
It's like sleeping on a big pillow. Yeah.
You think the pillow industry is rarely campaign.
Like we gotta sell it more pillows. What's going on. Those artist, Bob.
Hey, we got to get some pro pillow studies out there. I'm like
speaking of marketing though, you mentioned that, that MyPillow,
did we mention this? The, my pillow that, you know, I even know the name,
my pillow. Have you ever put your head on my pillow? No.
It's like a cinderblock. It's like it's, it's so uncomfortable.
It's it's hilarious. But you know, it's like that. I'm an American guy.
We made them hear this episode of history. Hyena is brought to you by my pillow.
Hello? Yeah. We have our worst thing. You gotta try it.
It's the sponsor of today's episode.
It's actually like the example for why everything went overseas.
When you buy it, you're going, like, I get it. Same thing with Casper mattress.
Everyone buys a Casper. It's like, those are good. Oh, are they? Oh yeah,
because then they also might sponsor.
Can I just say that guy looks like he's never held anything in his life?
Like it's the most awkward, like mannequin hands. Like this is comfort and the,
your hand it's very tasty. When you lie on it.
Good for you. My pillow can be yours as well.
My pillow is good for a while. Good for life. My pillow.
He looks like he he's an American kid. Oh yeah. You've never seen him.
Have you seen those infomercials? No. You've never seen them. [inaudible]
LA it's probably different infomercials. I mean now my pillows everywhere, man.
Yeah. It's like hipster commercials. Hey, uh, do you have a pillow of the past?
Check on my pillow. No, my pillows are everywhere, man. Yeah.
Let him see it. Fox.
You're saying that was my pillows. I love the sky. How much fill in there?
Keep your neck always just the definition of a guy. Just pause it for a second.
Yeah. I guarantee you that this guy doesn't make those pillows.
I guarantee you some huge company. That's like,
let's find the most normal American guy who you would meet at like a bar in the
middle of Wisconsin and just Rooney pillows. I mean, he's just like,
he doesn't even know what he's talking about. He's like,
do you have problems with your vertebrae? Okay. Then, uh, then slap, uh,
this three times lie on it on a Tuesday and you'll figure it out by Friday.
Yeah.
He also sort of shop the shop from where I want to shop.
They're all shopping. So all we need to get us the right, the right size.
Every pillow has a color quarter tag Greenland, Jean corded.
By the way, he sounds Amies hammer colors. Four pillars. So.
Soon with the yellow level, the yellow level, one.
Of the colors is women.
It's also for stomach sleeping. True. That's true.
And it's white, white women.
Petite women. A five foot four, 5.15.
All. It's hilarious. Yeah.
Yeah. That's perfect. Yellow like that child. Stomach sleeper. Yeah.
That's the last thing he wants your child chokes on its vomit.
Uh, uh, every, every woman, no matter what.
Huh? I've never seen this as popular as like the sham one.
How can you guys not see the MyPillow?
I haven't seen it cause they're not watching. Cause they're watching.
Like they're not watching TV at night. Like when they're drunk eat at like,
we watch TV is hard to avoid for a little while. It was every channel.
It's everywhere. It's also for a smaller man. I would say.
Yeah. I mean, he's making it up as he's going along.
This one's a dwarf pillow over here.
Smaller guys.
This one is for your crotch over here.
When you're alone in the middle of the night and you don't have another woman in
your bed, you put it between your legs and here we go.
And there's an extra pillow over here. There's one over here is when you're a,
you don't have that much money and you're splitting a hotel room.
What your buddy? But you don't want to feel like a homosexual.
She put this one between the other guy. It's a good wall. It's a straight wall.
He's just making it up as this talk.
And now I think he dropped out of a heart attack right now. He's still alive.
Oh, Billy Mays. Okay.
Yeah. It's almost all guys up to us. Maybe six.
Pillows for almost all guys.
Almost all the way up to an XL shooters.
And it's also for larger women.
Can you pause it for a second? Scott Jesus on his chest.
Have you ever walked into a hotel and seen a pillow and been like that?
One's not my size. Never extra large guys. Never. Yeah.
That one. Yeah. That pillow over there. That's so I could call front desk, like,
I'm sorry. You don't have the right size pillow for me. I'm a medium sized guy.
You got extra large guys. Every guy,
when they go to a hotel it's near this need to call down and go.
You gave me lady, bill, you gave me a lady pillow. I mean,
this guy couldn't be more full of, but he's is that a little Jesus Christ Jesus.
This is straight out of central casting. Now here's the thing about this pillow.
You will fall asleep for three days and rise. Three days later,
you'll get the best sleep of your life. We call this one, the Jesus,
this is the savior pill. This is the savior pillow
I made this.
That's just sleeps on her side.
That is broader shoulders because you need more height for your size,
your back for your stomach.
Willdabeast of a woman and you weigh 400 pounds.
This pillows for you and all your back issues. Now, if you want to kill someone,
this one's really going to hold over. Someone's failing to kill.
Yonis was father.
The, uh, the blue level is for one person. And that's the guy,
a guy that with over six foot one, a guy that's real broad stocking shoulders.
Cakes. Wait a minute. This is not for you.
I'm trying to remember how we went from Edison. Yeah.
Very true inventions.
Please do not buy this one because it's not going to go flat.
So none of my pillows do, they're going to stay. What you get is what it is.
Yeah.
So don't buy up thinking it's going to be like a conventional pillow that goes
flat. It's going to be the same on day one. As it is on yours,
you are so full of.
All pillows go down when you put your head on up. Yeah.
And that red pillow is for one person and one person only me.
It's it's a guy that is a huge shoulders.
Only sleeps on his side. He's the height. Oh, that's what it is.
His size sleeping to take the pressure off. Yeah.
Yeah. Imagine your boy.
And this is your life to be this guy. Oh my God.
Imagine like you look back at your life. You already death pick. I was like,
I was, I that's what I got, I was about pillows was the, my guy.
I was the MyPillow guy, but a bear me with my pillow. Wow.
There it is. Who you are. So this pill is only for one person. That's a large.
I couldn't find headphones. So I'm kind of just out. Sorry. I've been looking.
Another thing too with this all go with these colors.
All go for the same for last size pillows. Yeah. That works exactly the same.
You've got your finished sloppy in your yellow, white, green, blue,
and then the red and I can't.
He paused for a second. He's got four pillows on that table.
I cannot tell the difference between any of those pillows. No, like this.
If I went to his demonstration, I would be like, dude, I don't see a difference.
They all are the same pillow he could have. Those could be for the same pillows.
And he's saying, Oh, this one's woman pillow. This one's a man.
Love them up and down on the table. Yeah. He all four of them. Yeah.
I am thinking they're going to grow flat at night.
This is what my pillow is all about. It's going to stay where you put it in.
It's going to hold. They're like actively having a stroke. So important.
There's commercials to what I just said on the video here. Uh,
we do have the 69 60 day money-back guarantee,
but you're not going to want to re ever return this pillow. If you get fitted,
right. Obviously if you bought this blue pillow,
that's why I returned at venture neck or the outweigh.
You're not going to like it this way. Fitting is so important.
And if you follow what I just told you, it's going to be an amazing sleep.
So you got to watch that drunk instructional video to make sure you get your
pillow. Right? We'll get that. Yeah. I mean, look,
Nate park artsy did a MyPillow reveal. Third one down.